aufgewühlt und wütend sind sie und sie
haben nichts mehr zu verlieren
plötzlich trauen sich viele hunderte und
wollen gesicht zeigen gegen die taliban
und ihre helfer gestern in kabul
demonstriert die größte menge seit dem
zusammenbruch der alten ordnung es sind
vor allem frauen aber auch viele junge
männer laufen nicht alle die auf ein
besseres leben hofften in sprechchören
verfluchen sie pakistan dass die
verhassten taliban unterstützt
die welt soll endlich gerechtigkeit nach
afghanistan bringen dafür kämpfen wir
bis zum ende
hört auf damit ganze generationen
abzuschlachten wir wollen freiheit und
kleine pakistanische einmischung
was machen die pakistaner überhaupt hier
ihr taliban seit so stolz darauf dass
ihr die amerikaner vertrieben habt und
nun haben wir die pakistaner im land die
uns bekämpfen
die taliban laufen schwer bewaffnet
nebenher und lassen es zunächst
geschehen denn solchen widerstand hat
ihnen nicht einmal die afghanische armee
entgegen gesetzt und da wirken die
wilden krieger plötzlich für ein paar
momente hilflos im angesicht einer
mutigen zivilgesellschaft bis dann die
gewehre sprechen
[Musik]
und schon bald nach den wahren schüssen
kehrt die gespenstische ruhe zurück und
sie übernehmen wieder die kontrolle
selten offen aggressiv aber mit der
kühlen selbstgewissheit die aus den
läufen der sturmgewehre wächst stellen
sie sich zwischen ein volk und seine
zukunft
[Musik]
natürlich sind das keine netten leute
aber vor der einnahme kabul haben ihre
anführer die losung ausgegeben
haltet euch zurück verhaltet euch nicht
wie vor 20 jahren
wer sich so kleidet und das tut was sie
verlangen dem tun sie nichts aber wer
ihn nicht folgt und wer sich in sogar
wieder selbst wie bei diesen protesten
dem begegnen sie mit aller härte
und obwohl sie das weiß will sarah navi
nicht aufgeben sie arbeitet bei einem
frauensender in der hauptstadt dem die
taliban schon am ersten tag den stecker
zogen die 34 jährige kommt als einzige
noch ins büro ihre 50 kolleginnen
bleiben daheim wie die meisten frauen im
neuen afghanistan sie sind wie lebendig
begraben sagt die reporterin die im netz
weiter berichtet
auf ihrer pressekonferenz haben sie
verkündet wird von dies und ändern dass
über alles wurde gesprochen aber nicht
über frauen und da habe ich gefragt was
ist denn für die frauen geplant glauben
sie dass frauen keine menschen sind oder
nicht zu diesem land gehören und er
sagte nur
wenn das straßenbild jeder beliebigen
afghanischen stadt einen rückschluss
zulässt dann werden die taliban abermals
die frauen unsichtbar machen verhüllt
und gesichtslos sieht man sie über die
märkte huschen verunziert und entwürdigt
sind ihre fotos in den schaufenstern der
schönheitssalons den traurigen zeugen
des seitenwechsels
am ersten tag habe ich mein salon
geöffnet und da kamen sie gleich und
befallen mir auch die fotos in meinen
betrieben zu übermalen wir haben getan
was sie wollten denn wir hatten angst
dass wir uns wie
die wenigen kundinnen die heute noch zu
ihr kommen wollen nur schnell heiraten
um einer zwangsehe mit einem tarif zu
entgehen und so schnell wie möglich raus
aus dem land make up frisuren schönheit
waren im alten afghanistan eine
goldgrube jetzt traut sich keiner mehr
danach zu fragen das weiß auch der
besitzer des kosmetik ladens in der
menschenleeren einkaufsmall feine öle
hautpflege und grüner tee gesichtsmasken
ein sortiment wie aus einer anderen welt
das nicht mehr nachgefragt wird und dass
sich auch keiner mehr leisten kann
erspart es ist aufgebraucht die banken
sind zu
seit zwei wochen war keiner mehr hier
die leute trauen sich nicht mehr zu
kommen viele haben angst um ihr leben
auch im food court gähnende leere da
saßen sie früher mal zusammen männer und
frauen an sowas ist heute gar nicht mehr
zu denken
viele schmieden nun fluchtpläne niemand
traut den beteuerungen der taliban
keiner weiß wie es weitergehen soll es
ist als er bachmann aus einem langen
traum und plötzlich hat sich die welt
komplett gedreht sagt sarah
oft ist sie die einzige afghanische
journalistin die sich in die
pressekonferenzen der neuen machthaber
wagt der taliban-sprecher stellt die
übergangsregierung vor ein klub aus
fanatikern ex häftlingen und gesuchten
terroristen auch sarah nabu hat eine
frage
wird es auch ein frauenministerium geben
und wieder wird sie kühl beschieden mit
warten sie es ab
was es aber wieder geben soll ist eine
tugend behörde gegen laster und und
sucht im klartext ein ministerium für
angst und schrecken
genau das habe ich auch erwartet diese
leute respektieren frauen einfach nicht
für sie sind wir nicht mal menschlich
sie will übrigens nicht flüchten sondern
bleiben und sich den taliban
entgegenstellen